we welcome you to cbs this morning we're
going to begin with the extreme weather
that's here in the northeast now being
slammed by what's left of hurricane ida
the system is currently over new england
after cutting a destructive path
affecting at least 57 million people in
new york the entire subway system was
shut down due to flooding and many
drivers were trapped in their cars at
least 10 people were killed across the
area
in some breaking news united airlines
has suspended service at newark's
airport due to the conditions there the
system also spun off multiple tornadoes
including this one in bristol
pennsylvania mualengi is in middlesex
new jersey mola what are you seeing this
morning good morning
good morning vlad yeah middlesex new
jersey we're nearby bound brook
flooded overnight creating this mess
that you see here behind me as you can
see the roads impassable authorities
have it shut down nearby homes had to be
evacuated this morning and overnight but
really no matter where you were in the
northeast in the last 24 hours or so you
likely got clobbered by some sort of
severe weather between the flooding and
the tornado damage statistically in the
new york city area this type of rain
happens only once every 200 years
the storm set water pouring into new
york city subways overnight forcing all
trains to stop oh my god
rain flooded the streets reaching some
car
windows cars are floating
and lifting others right off the road
our cameras caught families evacuating
this middlesex new jersey neighborhood
as streets flooded i'm so sad i'm
terrified the house
my belongings my kid is so terrified the
national weather service issued a flash
flood emergency for the first time ever
in new york city
as strong winds blew rain sideways into
the covered u.s open stadium in queens
during a match forcing play to be
suspended
in brooklyn rescue crews worked to save
drivers trapped in the floods
and this biker found himself in
waist-deep water apparently trying to
deliver someone's dinner
meanwhile some buildings in manhattan
were no match for the flood
water rushing into this apartment parts
of the region got three inches of rain
in just an hour believed to be a record
in the area look at that tornado a
tornado tore through the southern part
of new jersey wednesday possibly the
strongest to ever hit the state it
ripped the sides off some homes and
turned others into a pile of rubble
the remnants of hurricane ida also spun
off other possible twisters in
pennsylvania and in maryland where a
tornado tore down power lines in the
annapolis area leaving this tangled mess
of trees and wires
the nearby raritan river is expected to
get 14 feet above flood stage by
tomorrow but as far as the storm the
remnants of ida tony that appears to be
behind us well that is good news mole
thank you very much